hello folks and before we get started i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by aspire
and once again more specifically some
classic star wars games they have going
on sale
right now and they're 50 off on nintendo
switch and xbox one 50
off on playstation 4 with playstation
plus 40 without on playstation 4 the
sale goes on until january 19th
xbox one and nintendo switch goes on
until january 21st so strike while the
iron's hot click the link below go to
aspire.com
star wars and whereas last time we
talked about the fun i had with episode
1 racer now we're going to talk about
jedi knight to jedi
outcast which is available on nintendo
switch and playstation 4. and what is
there to say about this game that the
internet hasn't already said it's a
classic star wars adventure but for me
it was the first adventure that i
really felt like a jedi i was like oh so
this is the adventure i've wanted all my
life
24 single-player missions and not gonna
lie still one of the classic
and best star wars games in my mind's
eye maybe it's nostalgia
i don't know so again click the link
below go to aspire.com
star wars and be the jedi and thank you
once again to aspire for sponsoring this
video
i do appreciate it all right i hope you
enjoyed the pep
and optimism of that sponsorship segment
there's no real way
to transition from that kind of energy
to talking about requiem for a dream so
we're just gonna do it in the words of
the jim carrey riddler
let's get real
[Music]
requiem for a dream so requiem for a
dream came out just over 20 years ago it
had its 20-year anniversary i believe it
was last october it came out in 4k
got it immediately directed by darren
aronofsky and it was my first
aronofsky experience it's kind of like
requiem for a dream for darren aronofsky
is like quentin tarantino and pulp
fiction
with me you know it's like the first
movie of theirs i saw
wasn't the first movie they had done but
i remembered their name after that and
ever since then i've been a darren
aronofsky fan
little known fact in the past couple
years or so when i
do a top 10 anticipated movies of the
year video
i specifically check to see if darren
aronofsky's doing a movie that year
because if he is
that movie's going on the anticipated
list and okay um
so wreck way in for a dream let's talk
about this movie that
cracks your soul to the core i i feel
like a lot of people's experiences with
requiem for a dream
are akin to mine this is my experience
and it's the experience i
generally get from people is they watch
it and after they
watch it they're just like that was
great
never going to watch it again but that
was great which i kind of for me
blamed the guy who pitched it to us you
know it was like
go back in time we were all 19 years old
my friends and i were all hanging out
and then my friend's roommate at the
time was like hey you guys seen requiem
for a dream like he was the artsy one
he was like oh you got to see this movie
rock queen for a dream and
ellen burst it you have to see it so
we're like oh [ __ ] he's really talking
this up
let's go rent it from blockbuster so we
did
we got a bunch of junk food and laid it
out on the table we're talking a lot of
junk food too
we lost 10 years off of our lives
from the movie 20 from the junk food the
point is though he didn't
really prep the room he should have been
like are you guys ready to change
as humans which is why i prep you in
that way maybe i'm over talking it maybe
i'm over hyping it but i'd rather have
you over prepped than under prepped
like i was so you have jared leto
jennifer connolly marlon wayans all
giving great performances and they all
live in this world of heroin whether it
be using it
dealing it or addiction and there's this
dry spell of
product that happens and things get
really real for them
also ellen burson plays jared leto's mom
who gets hooked on prescription meds so
she's on uppers they're on downers
and it does not even out it doesn't feel
like equilibrium it just
feels like total soul [ __ ] now that's
like you know the premise on the surface
and i'm sure people have done
deep dives of requiem for a dream on
youtube there are a lot of youtube
videos out there
in a world where i generally talk about
how a movie feels
you're just going to get my perception
of it but that's what i like about
darren aronofsky films you can show a
room of 10 people the same darren
aronofsky film
and they're gonna all have a very unique
takeaway from it requiem for a dream is
no different the simple matter that
you're dealing with two different
age groups that really works for this
one because i mean when i first saw the
movie i processed the movie a certain
way as i got a little older i saw it
again
processed it differently and now i
process it completely differently
because at first i was just kind of
more paying attention to jared leto and
marlon wayans jennifer connelly you know
the young crew not taking anything away
from ellen burstin from the get-go
always been a powerhouse performance and
you always know that no matter what age
you are when you watch this movie but
now it's her character that i'm more
attached to the older i get so every
time you watch this movie you just you
take
something else away from it not every
movie does that in fact very few do
is what makes requiem for a dream
endless and timelessly haunting
all right i'll cut the foreplay i've
teased enough ellen burstin in this
movie
this performance man i'll say this very
conscious
effort in noticing this this last time i
watched the movie
which was yesterday at the time i
uploaded this day before yesterday when
anyone's nominated for an oscar they get
an
oscar you watch the movie and you're
like oh that's the oscar clip has to be
or maybe you see a performance where
someone's really amazing and you know
they might get nominated and it's fun to
be like what's the oscar clip what are
they gonna play during the oscars oh
that's the oscar clip
i can't pick in here every clip every
scene
every monologue with her every dialogue
with her
there are so many clips where you're
like any of these can be oscar clips
she should have gotten the oscar for
best actress that year
she was nominated she lost to julia
roberts for erin brockovich
no disrespect to julia roberts and erin
brockovich but i think it's safely in
the realm of possibility and reality to
say ellen burstin
not winning the oscar that year was the
thing that made me
cease to take the oscars seriously at
all probably helps from the fact that it
is a hard hit
and it is a very tragic downward spiral
you just see her circling the drain the
entire movie until she gets closer and
closer and closer and like yeah we're
here now the entire
movie her entire performance
is just amazing also i love the camera
working here there's a very
unique stylistic way
that this movie's pulled off and filmed
it feels very
creatively indie it's the only way i can
put it you know if someone's making an
indie film they don't have the huge
budget so like well we have to film it
to look interesting
i just like the fact that there are some
directors that
thrive on a lower budget darren
aronofsky
he's just one of them whether it be that
tracking shot where ellen burstin's just
cleaning the entire room but it's sped
up but the camera is moving so slow
you're like
they must have filmed her for hours and
this camera was
barely moving then it sped up really
fast so she's like like lightning just
going through the house cleaning it up
but the point is it's a creative
technique
and it's a simple way to give you all
the information you need without wasting
your time
also that what i call the requiem for a
dream camera shot you know where it's a
camera
directly on someone just this attachment
to their chest
and they're walking and the background's
moving but they're not
i'm not saying requiem for a dream was
the first movie to use that camera
technique what i do know
is after requiem for a dream a lot more
movies started using that camera
technique it's just a hauntingly
effective way to keep
the camera on someone's face and it
gives you that sense of
almost an out-of-body experience and
i've seen directors use it in their
movies and you can tell us like
well we're not going for it's just cool
i wanted to do it which i totally get
and we're not getting out of here
without talking about the clint mansell
score
yeah i just found out the vinyl exists
snatch that up immediately that score
man it's a musical score
that is in fact so epic and so good
so haunting lord of the rings two towers
used it for the trailer
it shows the power in music you know it
shows the power in a musical score
because the music is every bit as
haunting as the movie
but it's a chicken in the egg scenario
is the music haunting because of the
movie is the movie more haunting because
of the music it's the symbiotic
relationship between film and musical
score
it just works perfectly in requiem for a
dream actually the biggest bummer of
requiem for a dream
is the fact that my mom's probably gonna
watch it now like there are movies i've
talked about for a couple
decades at this point snatch requiem for
a dream those are two of them
and she's always like i need to watch
that movie you know after the gentleman
came out i was like oh yeah guy richie
and snatch she was like i still need to
see snatch
sounds weird saying my mom's saying that
but it's what she said
but now you because i did this video
she's probably finally going to watch
requiem for a dream and mom
if you're gonna watch requiem for a
dream now if you're watching this
i know you are cause you're a supportive
mom you gotta remember the words of the
great illidan
you are not prepared
just know just know that you're gonna
walk out of this movie
different than the person you're gonna
be a different human when you walk out
of it than the person you were when you
went into it i'm not watching it with
you
sorry everyone has to let me or i could
watch it with you
until keith david comes on screen then
i'm bouncing i'm out
no keith david is amazing in this movie
too
amazingly creepy because he's a
charismatic creep anyone in that room
would be able to read the room read the
vibe that she's giving off
just put a stop to it but this is
requiem for a dream no one comes out of
this story unscathed you know the best
part about keith david being in this
movie
is if you're a fan of editing you can
make those spawn dialogues from mortal
kombat 11 a lot more interesting
oh i know it's pretty baby but i didn't
take it out for air
just lightening the mood i already know
this is one of those videos that after i
upload it i'm going to think of more
things
i would have wanted to say that i'm just
not thinking of now and next year i can
probably do a video on requiem for a
dream and it would
largely be a different video watch it
yearly at this point
because why not everyone who watches
this movie's like i'll never watch it
again but trust me
the gap between when i first saw it and
i saw it the second time
was much larger than now now it's just
like you know the gap gets smaller and
smaller until you watch it annually and
just kind of going to darren aronofsky
bender and
that's that that's my recharge for the
year but i have no doubt next time i'll
notice something
else and that'll just hit me and i'll
process it differently than i did the
last time and that's what makes requiem
for a dream a very unique experience for
me but what i'll say is i
love what this movie does in terms of
breaking down the perceptions
of addiction and addicts because we're
people and people like putting things
and other people in boxes you see it all
the time so it's easy to be like oh
that's addiction those are addicts
that's
their world over there this is my world
over here never the twain shall meet but
that's a
false security that's a false sense of
reality what requiem for a dream shows
is those two worlds are
not so separated not as separated
as you might like to think it really
hammers at home with ellen burstin's
character you know but it does show you
that that downward spiral you see
her going through it can really happen
to anybody something as simple as the
very
understandable wants to just
go back to a time where you might have
felt better about yourself can lead you
down the road to a very real and
personal hell and that's how addiction
happens no one's ever like hey
i want to be an addict today just sounds
fun it always starts out a different way
and it always leads you to a bad place
maybe it's weight loss pills because you
wanted to lose that weight maybe you had
surgery and hey here's a prescription
for vicodin
it's a very common thing it's a very
common story of addiction and that can
happen to anybody and that's a very
uncomfortable reality to deal with
but it is reality and it's particularly
crushing at this point where she's on
this train
and because you know her you know her
story
you know her intent you know the context
you know what she's trying to tell
people on this train
but also you see it from their
perception and she is just
jacked up wired up she looks like a mess
she's
sweating it makes you think about anyone
you may have seen as a tweaker that you
passed on the sidewalk or
been in a subway car with and it makes
you really ponder the story of how they
got there and it makes you grasp the
tragedy of it it brings a humanity to
addicts
and an understanding to addiction that's
largely
lacking in the end requiem for a dream
it's a very unique cinematic experience
it's probably it's not for everybody i
get that but if you can get there if you
can take three deep breaths
and make that dive and watch it you'll
take something away from it it's like
most of the movies i talk about on here
it's movies you know
we're here to enjoy ourselves have fun
very few times will i
say this movie is necessary viewing but
requiem for a dream is one of the times
i'm gonna use that card and say this is
necessary viewing at least once am i now
saying my audience needs to have their
soul
just fractured in some form from a movie
yeah absolutely but i will say this
requiem for a dream is easier viewing
than the news
[ __ ] i got no jokes that's just
that just is it'll take you to a dark
place but it's a place you gotta see at
least once
you know but i can't deny the talent the
impact it had on me the artistry of it
and every time i watch it i take
something else away
i notice something differently or i
suppose
more accurately put i process the movie
differently i internalize
it differently and that gives me a
different perspective
literally like watching a new movie
watching the movie for the first time
all over again great acting from
everyone powerhouse acting from ellen
burstin the musical score is hauntingly
epic and requiem for a dream
is awesome tacular
you did it folks you made it i'm so glad
some of you gonna watch requiem for a
dream
don't blame me or so requiem for a dream
have you seen it why did you think about
it whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you